it's panel and we will begin with
Alexandra childer trova and she's at the
height school at Carnegie Mellon thank
you everyone and thank you so much to
the organizers for inviting me to speak
here I'll start by saying that I'm a
statistician by training but the work
that I'm presenting here is an entirely
qualitative analysis there was no
randomised sampling or anything along
those lines on the other hand I hope
that this presentation is responsive to
at least one of the comments that was
raised during the strategizing session
which is this question around design so
if how do we design better systems what
sort of information can we collect how
can we do better how can we better frame
the sorts of technical problems that is
Cynthia articulated we and the more
theoretical community might be able to
address so this research is
collaboration between Rima who's a
health economist in New Zealand myself
the statistician at Carnegie Mellon and
Pittsburgh and Pennsylvania Emily Putnam
Hornstein who's a social work researcher
and a team of participatory designers
out of New Zealand so the primary
motivation for our work is that
algorithmic systems whether they're
algorithm assisted or fully automated
systems are increasingly being adopted
by governments seeking to improve their
processes and the outcomes for the
citizens who they are supposed to assist
in support however we understand now
either through media coverage or by
paying in this room to begin with that a
lot of these systems are somehow risking
perpetuating harm and discrimination and
effecting negative outcomes all while
operating outside of traditional
oversight and accountability mechanisms
and what we hope to do with this study
is try to understand what does kind of
accountability and what does
transparency and what does fairness look
like if you talk to affected communities
so these aren't necessarily the people
who are sitting in the room with you as
you are thinking about well here's a
that we're building are you going to
purchase it these are the people who are
most likely to be using these tools for
the people who are most likely to have
these tools used on them and the three
central questions that our study sought
to answer is as follows so first we were
interested in how do the people who are
most likely to be subject to or affected
by algorithmic decision-making in our
case focus on the child welfare context
how do those people feel about the
deployment of such systems what are the
primary sources of discomfort in these
communities surrounding the development
and deployment of such tools and lastly
what can we as researchers or designers
or developers what can we do in the
development design and deployment stages
to improve comfort among affected
communities and when we were thinking
about these questions we tried to
examine them in connection to two
concepts that are more common to the
analysis of corporate operations rather
than government operations so namely
these are the ideas of social license
and organizational justice social
license is not necessarily a popular
term but we thought it was a useful lens
in our context it refers to roughly
community and stakeholder acceptance of
a company's operating procedures and
business practices and this can be
compared to what some people rightly
point to which is the need for stricter
regulations however what we contend is
that algorithmic systems that are
deployed in full compliance with
governing regulation and governing laws
may nevertheless fail to achieve license
to operate they may fail to achieve
community acceptance and we believe that
this community acceptance is important
because as someone who works on
developing these sorts of tools so and I
have answered in the affirmative the
question should we build it at least
sometimes the potential that these
algorithmic systems are viewed to have
and in promoting positive social change
may fail to be fully realized because
these systems will be met without the
opposition and sometimes not entirely
justifiably so so we want to build trust
or these systems but then there's a
question of how do we actually get
people to trust them and also what does
trustworthiness mean in the first
and in the context of organizational
justice what we thought about were
elements such as procedural
interpersonal and informational justice
these turned out to be very important
when we were looking at the results of
our workshops so procedural justice for
those of you who are not familiar with
this idea it's and a really important
concept especially in this context
because it's one element that's been
found to mitigate the relationship
between outcome favorability and support
or acceptance of decisions so this has
been studied in the employment of
promotion context that even if you
yourself were not selected for promotion
if you believe that the process is
procedurally just you may nevertheless
be accepting of that outcome this refers
to roughly the perceived accuracy
meritocracy fairness and ethics
associated to decision an other element
that turns out to be quite important is
interpersonal or interactional justice
which is for instance how information is
delivered to you whether you actually
treated by individuals in this process
with dignity and respect and these are
perhaps not elements that we think about
as we're designing algorithms but as
I'll indicate later these are really
important things that we can actually
affect in the design process so how do
we do this
well we adopted a participatory design
framework and this workshopping
approach is just a sub component of that
and participatory design is basically
this approach to try to incorporate the
individuals who are going to be most
affected by the system into the role of
designing it so make sure that their
opinions and beliefs are heard up front
what we basically did was the following
we were talking to I'll describe the
participant group in a minute but we're
talking individuals where we could not
really assume a level of technical
sophistication or a level of numeracy so
what we did was we adopted this comfort
board which was previously used by our
design collaborators when studying the
idea of data ethics and data sharing and
there are two axes here which are not
formally defined so we think of these as
kind of common sense
ideas one of them is the perceived
benefit where the further out you are on
the x-axis the higher the perceived
benefit is and the other access is trust
right so the higher you are on the
vertical axis the higher your level of
trust is so what do these roughly
correspond to we're gonna walk or we did
walk the participants through various
scenarios benefit is kind of the
perceived benefit that they believe
could result from the action taken and
Trust is kind of how much trust they
actually have either in the system or
the actors that you know the system is
kind of operating well that this is a de
gotcha moment things along those lines
right these were not formally defined
what we did try to articulate is that
roughly the de Ganahl corresponds to a
level of comfort again qualitatively
defined we didn't try to precisely say
what comfort means but individuals who
are very low on the trust and benefit
scale winds to be said to have very very
uncomfortable individuals who are up
here in the light area are more
comfortable with our study consisted of
five workshops in a single US County and
in total we engage with eighty three
participants which consisted of families
these are the individuals who might
think of if I told you that I was to run
a study with affected communities in the
child welfare system okay so these are
actually families who have had
encounters with the trouble Francisco
but we also considered two groups who
are frontline providers and specialists
these are individuals who actually work
in the child welfare system the
distinction between them is that
frontline providers are individuals who
actually engage with families so these
may be for instance caseworkers service
providers people who actually go out and
speak to families specialists are the
people who are more likely to be using
the tool so these are the people who for
instance student call centers who make
administrative decisions they understand
the details of cases but they're not the
ones who are actually going out and
having interactions with the families
so one thing I'll point out because I
think it's quite important in these
contexts in order to get families to
provide us with what we felt like was
freeform feedback we ensured that peer
support people were present at the
family workshops so peer support people
for those of you who are not familiar
with this they're quite commonly used in
child welfare and also for instance in
rehabilitation these are individuals who
have previously gone through the system
they have experience with this and they
may provide comfort and support in these
kind of difficult situations where there
might for instance be an imbalance in
authority or perceived distrust with the
facilitators of these workshops the
other thing is that most of the
frontline providers miss the family
participants were women this reflects
the disproportionality of kind of
employment and gender in these contexts
and one of the workshops actually
specifically focus on participants
identifying as persons of color and will
prior studies and I think the privacy's
have been mentioned in in this workshop
have found significant differences in
perceptions of especially procedural
justice across racial and ethnic groups
we didn't actually notice all that much
of a difference right so there is a
difference in terms of one participant
self described their experiences and
when those experiences were self
described as being based on being a
person of color caught up in the system
however while there may have been
differences in degree many of the
general concerns that were articulated
and a sort of information that was being
requested was actually consistent over
all but one thing I'll get back to you
later is that again this does not mean
that your race does not matter in the
system or your perception will be the
same regardless because we did not
measure degree and when we get to
talking about solutions it's not
entirely clear that the same solution is
going to be kind of a one sizes
so in order to actually be able to
elicit some meaningful feedback about
comfort levels with the use of
algorithms what we did was we developed
fictional a series of fictional
scenarios they're actually six of them
though D contains two sub scenarios and
we called this Nicole story so we asked
participants to imagine that they are
the parent of a young girl named Nicole
and we facilitated a series of fictional
events that unfold as Nicole grows up so
initially she's a child and her mother
gets caught up in the child welfare
system because Nicole ran out of the
house and eventually it goes to Nicole
having a child herself at the age of 16
and so on and so forth so the way that
we developed these scenarios is that we
started with something that would be
most proximate to the participants
experience and we evolved it into a
scenario where we had basically fully
algorithmic decision-making using a huge
amount of data casting a very wide net
and roping and providing information to
individuals who typically would not have
it and in developing these scenarios the
entire research team was involved in
that process but what we realized is
that some of the knobs that we wanted to
to to tune and some of the things we
wanted to investigate just would not
come across to the audience so we had a
prototyping session to make sure that at
least we could study a smaller subset of
elements but in a way that was
understandable so we get meaningful
feedback perhaps on a more restricted
set what are the sorts of knobs that we
tuned so we tend whether the decision
was proactive or reactive a reactive
decision would be for instance a call
comes in to the child abuse hotline and
the system needs to react right and
there may be an algorithm involved in
providing like a risk score just as in
criminal justice to support that
decision then we toggled whether it was
human decision-making algorithm assisted
decision-making or entirely algorithmic
decision-making so was there a human in
the loop was there an algorithm in the
loop and the last thing that we toggled
is the sort of data that was used so was
it
child welfare specific data did the
state also include criminal justice
information was the information that was
used put
should the community datas is something
that was not actually specific to the
individual but broadly obtained from the
community where they reside so these
workshops were facilitated that's and in
scenario one a we basically had
individuals position themselves on a
comfort board this is just a basic
against scenario as I described where a
child ran away from home was later found
in this rope to the mother into the
child welfare system and later on
instead of having people position on
this large board we position them on
this smaller board with their anonymized
named pieces and a sort of analysis that
were able to perform on the basis of
this data looks kind of like this so
this is a comfort board broken down by
families frontline providers and
specialists the darker colors indicate
places where there were more individuals
positioned on that cell this is for one
of the scenarios and we see here that
there is sample sizes are really small
don't read too much into this but we see
in general that overall we have pretty
like low or moderate comfort express
with whatever the scenario was this is
one see and that's actually the trend
overall we saw very few cases where
there was a very high comfort in the
decisions but 0.1 out later on we tried
to do there's an executive report that
actually came along with the research
activities what we tried to do is
actually give voice to the individuals
who participated in our workshops so a
lot of the report is in kind of us
speaking a lot of the academic paper is
us talking about the findings but a lot
of the report is actually quotations
from the participants that are kind of
reflective of and the broader feedback
that we received and it's quite
interesting so there's a fair bit of
variation across families but one of the
things that we'll see over and over and
over again so variation across
participants one of the things that
we'll see over and over and over again
is what's articulate in that first
family bubble just this idea of complete
distrust in the system I can't have any
faith in the data because I don't have
any faith in the justice system
pertaining to a case where we said that
we would use criminal justice data well
similar issues with just being in this
child welfare
altogether I think it was Nancy Krieger
yesterday who pointed out that mistrust
is actually not an issue with the
individual this is something that for
which the system is typically to blame
and that's something that we see over
and over and over again it's not the
algorithms or it's not solely the
algorithms it's generally the system so
what are some of the concerns that arose
through the sort of study so first of
all system level concerns were by far
the most common reasons for low comfort
in both Howell rhythm assisted and
algorithmic decision-making and this is
because the concerns that individuals
had about the child welfare system which
come from their prior experiences in the
system and the biases that they've
experienced we're readily projected onto
any kind of youths or sub-module within
this system that if you don't trust the
system in which this algorithm operates
you're not going to trust the algorithm
and this has been articulated in various
ways across the groups so for instance
this idea of investigation isn't some
sense already skewed it's always been me
against the system it feels like a
deficit model let's weigh up all the
dirty things in your life and nothing
good like this is everything we've seen
before right what's new about the
algorithm I ordered you to distress the
system the groups also raised
significant concerns relevant to this
workshop about the potential bias on the
part of caseworkers in the decision
process and also bias in the data or the
algorithm so a lot of the individuals
both white and black this is a we're
operating in a county where there isn't
a very large Hispanic population so the
study really did focus on white and
black participants so for instance
families are taking they did that the
system here in America just lets us down
especially if you're black someone said
how honest are we allowed to be most of
our systems were not made for people of
color by people of color or have people
of color in them and then this latter
point is actually quite interesting and
it pertains to the sort of data that's
actually contain an administrative
records and I think it's highly incisive
and with this person is basically saying
is that if you have if you're in a
wealthy neighborhood and you have access
to private health care and private
rehabilitation services or just privacy
in general
your substance abuse issues or your
mental health issues these are not going
to show up on our administrative records
so the individuals on whom we will have
the greatest data resolution are
necessarily going to be the ones that
already have prior public welfare
engagement and perhaps already have a
pretty stressful system there were many
concerns about whether statistical model
could account for context that we need
them where humans in the loop approach
right how do these systems how does the
incorporation of algorithmic systems
actually impact the interpersonal
relationships again this quote from the
family computer cannot understand
context perhaps okay most logistic
regressions don't understand context is
for sure my son has autism how does the
data account for this so when we take
when we say that well if you have just
if you haven't human-in-the-loop this
will decrease accuracy well for whom
right now what are we missing if we
completely remove the people from the
decision-making process right accuracy
on a single metric isn't necessarily the
name of the game
participants certainly wanted more
transparency or information on how the
algorithm weighs different factors and
abilities to dispute the score so
Deirdre Mulligan gave a fantastic
keynote I think she's in there somewhere
at the fat star conference Rison that
talked about contestability this is
really important it's not just a concern
that's it that's articulated at kind of
the legal of levels the second star
indicated by affected communities and
lastly there were lots of concerns about
how and whether risk information was
communicated to families and caseworkers
so in particular even clearly beneficial
decisions where everyone agreed yes I
can see the benefit here that those
efforts were undermined by the fact that
there was a mention of a statistical
model in the first place and the way
that it was mentioned so let me just
conclude on this last point which is
what can researchers and designers do in
development and employment stages to
raise comfort levels I know this is
based on of the discussions that we had
following the individual kind of
placements on the board and also these
and the synthesized attempts at the end
right so each of these workshops lasted
for a few hours there was lots of
discussion about like why
why is your comfort level here what can
we do to improve it
what can you vision about the system and
let me tell you one thing which is that
just disclosure and numbers dumps it's
not gonna actually solve the problem in
particular the more precise information
that we provided in the one scenario we
had the opportunity to think about this
the less trust there was in the system
here's a scenario where we had a
proactive model so this is an at Birth
model that flagged Nicole now 16 who
just had a baby as potentially high-risk
and offered her voluntary beneficial
services but said that she was
identified as high-risk on the basis of
statistical model this is the comfort
board so specialists view this as being
a decision they're very comfortable with
where as families and individuals who
work with families did not entirely
agree so these are the people who are
getting the information about the tool
and these are the individuals who kind
of most directly affected by it when we
provided more information so we actually
said kind of how accurate the tool was
the more accurate the tool was in
assessing risk so it went from you know
one in five mothers identified as neat
and identified as needing support go on
to have bad outcomes
to four out of five mothers identified
as needing support go on to have bad
outcomes if they don't know if they
don't get services trust actually
dropped along the way all right
so kind of the better the tool is the
worse the trust level became and why is
that it's because there's an issue in
communication you can't just say it's
just a model present numbers that might
convince people in this room and expect
that to be good so let me just conclude
with this slide so what we concluded in
this study is that effective decision
strategies really need to consider how
technological solutions can be designed
to work in concert with complementary
policy changes to impact community
perceptions of the system justice so it
is not going to be enough to introduce
transparency or explain ability or do a
numbers dub or produce the regression
model all these things are things that
we can do we as designers are completely
willing to but there's an issue with how
for instance interpersonal relations are
actually affected whether I present you
information on the last time that you
relapsed or how long you've been clean
whether this is positive or negative
information this anchors individuals in
different ways and it affects the
interpersonal interactions that people
have and fundamentally the way that the
system is governed right now those
interpersonal relationships are really
the basis upon which everything rests
and if we cannot promote trust at that
level then there's very little that
we're going to be able to do to move the
needle with technological solutions
[Applause]
wondering if an accurate tool that says
there's a high chance we're going to
take the peak review makes people feel
that the system is against others yeah
man it's entirely interpretation all
right okay I don't think that's what we
think it's right right when I tell you
my child has higher positive
values than your tool you might view
that as a reach the research strata but
you would agree that my tools the one
that should be deployed right said this
is where I think what we jump to as our
table of numbers is what
even though this Ridge disclosure may be
important but you're absolutely right
that's exactly thanks okay the next
speaker is a clipton from computer
science department at CMU
hi everyone so first thanks to the
organizers for for having me here it's
been a really interesting session in
that I think a lot of us I guess from
the computer science side have had dealt
with these issues in a way that crosses
from maybe the technical into the
interdisciplinary but not crossed
completely over into the other
disciplines and so we talked about race
and technical systems in the context of
technical systems but not necessarily
seeing how these concepts are dealt with
outside of the context of technical
systems and in particular I like to
build on a couple main points that come
up over the last day last day and a half
you know one kind of recurring theme
yesterday was this sort of peril of
having problematic definitions and
concepts and race itself being that
problematic concept and maybe what would
be a bit different here is there were in
a situation of inheriting a flawed
concept in being stuck in a world that
has an entire literature and academic
culture that is built around this flawed
concept in figuring out what to do with
it and perhaps in the context of some of
the modern discussion on fairness and
interpretability we're in danger of
creating the flawed concepts ourselves
of misrepresenting what we're doing or
what problems we are solving by
attaching names that don't maybe
accurately describe what we're doing
there's also another point that I'll be
maybe building on that came up in a lot
of other talks from the other side which
is this idea of outsourcing these social
problems to technocrats and the danger
that what we end up doing is creating a
sort of reductive formulation of a lot
of these problems where we can sort of
purport to solve them but what we've
solved is our sort of like all of the
important things have fallen in the
cracks between the sort of reductive
definitions we can come up with and
actual underlying problems we're
purporting to solve so I'll try to go
through my slides relatively quickly I
have a couple more slides and I have
minutes so off to move fast and maybe
skip over a few things
but sort of I'll try to pick on from two
examples in the context of both fairness
and interpretability
so in general I just want to clarify
that here we have a diverse community as
talking about these issues in the
context of various technical systems not
all machine learning systems some in the
context of genetic testing in particular
my lens just given that it's the only
thing where I have some modicum of
expertise the lens that I approaches
issues from is the use of machine
learning being a machine learning
practitioner and scientist and in
particular while there's a lot of
research on a lot of different types of
supervised learning nearly all these
sort of operationalize systems in the
world that we are actually talking about
usually it's some form or another
supervised learning systems so they're
cases where we don't know how to program
a computer to do precisely what we want
it to do just by writing a set of rules
but we do have access to some data set
of you know given some inputs what is
the corresponding output that we might
like to see we feed it into some
algorithm that spits out a model and
this model now we can feed through a
data that we've never seen before and we
hope that the answer will look something
like the output that we would have liked
to see if we were manually annotating
them neural networks sort of get thrown
around I think in it perhaps it a
misleading way here at neural networks
are just one among many classes of
models that are used to solve these
kinds of approximation problems and to
extract patterns and you know there's
there's many other tools and I think
sometimes maybe because they are new a
lot of times problems that are maybe
like universal problems are being cast
as problems of neural networks or maybe
were actually their problems at that
paradigm entirely deep learning which is
the term that gets thrown around a lot
just means big neural networks you know
it's important to note that while we
have a tendency as a society and I think
we're guilty of this often as
practitioners in this field of assigning
all kinds were like anthropomorphic
qualities to what's going on a machine
learning like basically all we're
talking about is curve fitting systems
right we stick in some data we try to
approximate some outputs given some
inputs that's it you know there's a nice
sort of critique of
how we've sort of settled from this by
Udo Perl who's been on the I guess he's
been on the warpath on social media and
various other medias is an article in
the Atlantic where he kind of makes his
stand against maybe our myopic vision
and a curve fitting land so you know I
think a big problem here is that
fundamentally we're often just doing the
wrong thing and the entire casting of a
problem right is wrong like we are
applying supervised learning in general
like what supervised learning is good at
is given data offline from some
distribution you know where some
patterns hold in it we can extract some
pattern which would hold if we saw data
that came from the exact same
distribution that generated data on
which we trained and this is just
fundamentally not what we're actually
you know like there's a fundamental sort
of problem mismatch with almost
everything that we actually use machine
learning for like that's not in and of
itself useful what's actually useful to
a business is like making a decision and
so almost always we're actually
concerned with making a decision usually
with some kind of intervention there are
cases I think where you know there's not
really a you know a closed loop where
what we're doing is so close to a pure
super you know if we're doing pathology
and we're trying to recognize does
someone have or not have intestinal
parasites based on a microscope image
we're doing you know it's unlikely that
correctly identifying intestinal
parasites is going to change what images
look like in the future and so you know
it's ok you know we get away with the
fact that there there's maybe you know
maybe the data distribution is changing
a little bit over time there's subtle
violations of the machine learning
contract but they're they're not so
severe but in general when it comes like
businesses recommender systems we're
just doing something fundamentally wrong
we're participating in a system of
incentives the way we make decisions
influences the behavior of the people
who are interacting with the systems
I think recidivism which has come up
many times here is a clear case of just
four fundamentally addressing you know
putting someone in jail as a punishment
I so so you know it's like if I punch
someone in the face I would increase the
the risk that they would commit a crime
themselves in the next few days and yet
they shouldn't be punished
on account of me punching them in the
face right but you know we're sort of
mistaking like what is like there's
something fundamentally philosophically
wrong often with what we're addressing
is just not a prediction problem we want
some kind of intervention and it's not
really what we're dealing with so
there's all kinds of you know mismatches
between whatever our real world Jezza
darada is and what is provided by
supervised learning on the other hand
supervised learning sort of works in the
sense that you can build operational
systems that provide some kind of
economic value so we sort of we overlook
this we overlooked the fact that we have
we're addressing the wrong tasks we're
calling something a prediction problem
that's not a prediction problem we're
inserting it in the world in a way that
distorts behavior and changes the
distribution and so you know we have a
growing literature is now on sort of the
cat's prong different one looks at sort
of disparities that emerge from the use
of these problems say we need to somehow
correct the algorithms to make them fair
others that say you know the problem is
actually the inscrutability of the
models that you can't look inside the
model so people are saying that actually
what we just needed to make the models
interpretable and if you make them
interpretable then these problems go
away
and the real danger is you know if we
cast these problems the wrong way we run
a risk of actually being like bad actors
in in the fight that I think we're
trying to be on the right side of
because there's you know a big danger
that what we end up doing is actually
giving you know and I think it's as
points been made more articulately in
the previous talks I mean particularly
think Jonathan Rojas poke you know about
this danger that we will sort of like
the outsourcing of judgment to sort of
technocrats I think we run the risk of
of giving the the purported tools that
you know are sort of a claim to solve
these problems and here's an example I
made a editorial decision to censor the
tweeter so I can report only the tweet
and everyone is bound by honor and I'll
take google it so I don't feel bad so
you know I think this kind of thing is
real data so this is someone I guess I
could plagiarize a send deal or
something this is ah I won't say where
this person worked that it rhymes with
Google someone you know
I sort of accused and actually the
threat is kind of Loony because it's the
president on the other side of the
thread is like sort of you know someone
who writes 9000 treats or whatever
somehow we got engaged this prominent
machine learning researcher who sort of
responsive like you know says
accusations that they're doing bad
things and says well look there's many
papers including from my group like
we're making progress on this and I
think there's a big danger that sort of
it's become sort of cover like if you
look at the functional role that that
we're playing in a lot of companies that
so they could say hey you know we take
this issue seriously we have a team that
works on it and the danger is that if
what we're providing is not actually
solving a problem even if our intentions
are good we can end up sort of giving
someone the algorithmic fix it allows
someone to continue doing qualitatively
exactly what they're doing but to attack
you know prefects fair in front of it
and then you know we sort of you know
become complicit I think likely
unwittingly I think people don't mean
badly so first side you know right so we
I think you've heard about all the ways
that sort of algorithms can be bias in
particular in the context of supervised
learning right there's many things that
you know that what we mean by bias is
many sort of failure modes that we sort
of lump together under this term some
things are when groups are
underrepresented some issues or when
labels themselves might be themselves
fundamentally have errors that are
actually biased right like if you have
something that is a weak surrogate for
some notion of employee quality but the
employee quality is the judgment of
existing managers in thing of themselves
like they could it could actually be
truly biased like in a statistical sense
we could just be optimizing models
fundamentally for the wrong task
altogether we could even have the
problem that like the tasks may not be
equally easy for both groups so Yamaka I
made this point on a panel that were on
recently said someone talked about the
under-representation of people and face
recognition datasets and made the point
that even if you equally represented
people you suffer the problem that
there's already a certain kind of bias
baked into the way that digital
photography was design in the first
place in terms of the assignment of
dynamic range to different parts of the
color spectrum and so that it's more
difficult to recommend to recognize
darker faces and lightest cases just
because of how a sort of photos render
right so you know and these issues are
complicated by the fact that in the data
that we inherit all of our features are
related with each other protected
features like that my graphic membership
or associated with all of our Co various
are also associated with our labels of
interest and also subject measurement
error so then on the other side we say
well you know what what is the you know
I think as algorithms people we end up
looking to the law for some kind of
inspiration of like well what are we
supposed to do here so people end up at
least you know in a sort of us centric
kind of fairness literature often
turning to the notions of
non-discrimination that emerge from
title 7 of the Civil Rights Act of 1964
and in particular concepts of disparate
treatment and disparate impact so this
for treatment doctrine is you know these
are both complicated doctrines that have
like the main thing I want to articulate
here these are complicated doctrines
that have aspects that are not captured
in any current like machine learning
treatment of these problems district
treatment is concerned with decisions
that are explicitly based on a protected
characteristic but it's a little bit
more subtle than that you are allowed to
use protected characteristics in certain
contexts and it's not called disparate
treatment if you are using a protected
characteristic in the service of
something like promoting diversity that
is considered a state interest you also
there's a notion of intentionality
associated here which you know raises
the question of the applicability of the
law how well it describes a technical
system where perhaps nobody has any
intention involved and yet you can still
have discrimination of arise regardless
you have a notion of disparate impact
which talks about an unjustified adverse
impact on members of a protected class
and here you know you look at basically
along some demographic and there's
actually a very complicated law the
first step is a plaintiff has to
demonstrate that there's some kind of
disparity then the defendant can come
back and have to argue that the
decisions are justified and the
plaintiff has to come back and now show
the defendant can achieve the goal their
business goal with some kind of
alternative practice that would have
less disparity and so all of the
components of this like justification
is not something that sort of is well
articulated within technical paradigm
and this third notion here of like an
alternative practice sort of like speaks
to a kind of counterfactual reasoning
that the tools we have are not actually
doing so if a whole literature on fair
supervised learning that basically takes
supervised learning and adds in addition
to features and targets a sensitive
feature and some way or another says
let's try to output now a fair model so
you know we say we have to make groups
equal somehow but the question is how so
there's a whole sort of catalog of ways
that we try to make groups equal visiter
the combination of the features and a
protected attributes and also you know
the outputs of our model and you know we
have a tendency which i think is a very
dangerous one in our community to call
these fairness definitions which i think
is problematic because they they are not
dead none of them we have you know they
say we have nine million technical
definitions of fairness truths we have
zero technical definitions of fairness
we have many you know various postulates
like you know proposed statistical
parodies of interest that are somehow
related to our interest in formalizing
fairness but do not in and of themselves
like they don't possess the right
ingredients they're missing you you can
come up with any number of cases for any
one of these definitions where it's
either like seems like a very fair thing
to do to try to optimize this kind of
parity or seems like the most unfair
thing you possibly can do and that
difference depends upon quantities that
are that are extra statistical
quantities right like the difference
between why you should say that like I
should be concerned about outcome
disparities between say like black and
white Americans use of you like college
entrance is but I should not necessarily
be pushing for absolute uniformity
between say like white and Asian
Americans has to do with a knowledge
that we have that isn't captured just in
the formalism that says you know I have
covariates sensitive covariance and
prediction is this there's something
else that's not captured there so what
so blindness is a formalized saying
let's just not look at the sensitive
feature this sort of impact parity is
what people do is they say well we're
going
this condition that you know has to hold
as something as equal and it's gonna
depend on the sensitive feature and
there's a whole set of algorithms that
are proposed called disparate learning
process that I guess Alex and I call
them disparate learning processes in a
paper this is joint work of Alex and
Julia McCauley where basically people
proposed a whole bunch of algorithms
that come up with ways of trying to say
let's not look at the sensitive feature
because we think you're not supposed to
do that because of a potentially wrong
interpretation of what disparate
treatment means in the law as it's been
you know formalizing it perhaps
incorrectly in technical ways I think we
also don't want to have impact disparity
so we're gonna try to sort of thread the
needle and have a model that's accurate
subjective having impact parity without
without looking at the sensitive feature
and the problem with this is that first
of all it's not clear that you're not
actually allowed to look at the
sensitive feature if the interest is for
the sake of increasing diversity so it's
possible that the the problem that we're
trying to solve is itself contrived and
further the problem is that it turns out
actually looking at the feature if your
goal is to reconcile having an accurate
model with having sort of demographic
parity looking at the feature is the
optimal thing to do and so if it turns
out that you're non sensitive features
actually encode the the sensitive
feature that your models gonna up doing
functionally the identical thing that
it's going to do so we end up proposing
a solution that is functionally
identical to what you get from an
unconstrained classifier but we call it
fair and as a big danger on the other
hand if you know if you can't fully
recover if you can't fully infer
someone's race or someone's gender from
the non sensitive features then you end
up having all kinds of bizarre side
effects one of them is that basically
the model just looks for proxies and so
we end up coming up with a model is
explicitly doing this sort of like most
procedurally like unfair thing which is
that it's rather than to saying
explicitly we want to equalize things we
land up creating a model that is tries
to achieve the equalization on the basis
of proxy variable so in this like
synthetic example we have a model that
tries to use hair lengths when it's not
allowed to use say gender and in
real example with masters admissions
decissions we actually find is that you
know so if you if you take the model and
you try to predict with the same model
class is someone female or not this is
admissions to masters in CS you get you
know some scatter and if you also try to
train the model which is presumably what
you would do if you were just using
machine learning to guide admissions
predict admissions outcomes you predict
whether or not someone will get admitted
you predict whether or not someone's
female and then you apply one of these
you know fare classifiers off-the-shelf
what it ends up doing is it helps a lot
of men it hurts a lot more men and then
it makes a small to most of the
decisions that get flipped or actually
men who get flipped to negative and men
who get flipped to positive and then
there's a smaller number of flips among
women but what ends up happening is
basely the the women who the model
thinks are more likely to be men are
hurt by the classifier and the women who
are it thinks are more likely to be
women do benefit if they're just a
little bit below that acceptance
threshold but the dangerous thing is you
look into it and say so what is it that
makes someone likely to be male and it
turns out to be things like what they
want to study or who they want to study
with or which group they want to be part
of so you end up you know by neglecting
the fact that like we're participating
in a system of incentives we create the
system that is actually in a way like a
reinforcement of stereotypes basically
says hey if you're a woman and you want
to benefit from this policy that is
trying to increase the number of women
then you have to do you have to say that
you want to work in HCI not in theory
because it just so happens that there
are more women who apply in the
historical data to that group versus the
other group and so you know if we if we
don't look at these things if we just
look at you know in a very kind of naive
way you run a big risk just I guess very
quickly well I'll just touch on is that
you know a whole bunch of other people
are attributing the problem saying
actually you have a lot of papers that
say hey machine learning is used in all
these critical ideas you know if
critical settings that's very dangerous
and the models we don't know what
they're doing if only we could look
inside the model then these problems go
away the problem is like you know
presumably there's something about you
know the model itself it's the
inscrutability the model is somehow at
the core is problems and that if there
was only something we could
in the model besides this prediction
somehow this is gonna solve everything
the problem here is that basically these
papers sort of make this leap from that
to just proposing a solution and then
generating some kind of figure and
saying look our models interpretable but
what's never actually articulated is
what is interpretability in the first
place and how does it address any of
these fundamental underlying problems
and basically what I want is you know at
some point and I guess I don't have much
time so I it you can go I guess read the
paper but fundamentally you know the
problem with interpretability is that it
sort of ends up being a wastebasket
taxon so does anyone here know what an
antelope is so you think you know what
an antelope is maybe but it's you know
an antelope is not in it's not-it's not
not a coherent categorization of animals
there is no species called antelope
right it's like all the horned animals
that kind of look like a deer that we
don't have like a stronger affinity for
having bothered to give it a name for we
call them antelopes and so a lot of you
know the autumn are more related to a
water buffalo are more related to a deer
more related to something else so what
we've done is we've sort of created sort
of the wrong I think taxonomy if you
actually read through the papers which
is I tried to figure out you know what
is it that these definitions have in
common or what is it that
interpretability truly is you know it's
this weird mixture of people sort of
talking about out of domain robustness
without actually really dealing with it
or sort of punting to a similarly murky
concept which is trust without really
saying what what is it that should make
a model trustworthy or sort of opining
in the introduction about causality
without actually doing any work that
fundamentally addresses problems of
drawing you know correct causal
inferences and so you have this whole
literature you know the consists of you
know on one hand different ways of
saying that models should be simple or
have you know interpretable coefficient
without actually doing that or models
that consist of like squinting at a
learned model in trying to draw some
kind of qualitative insight by you know
poking at the neurons or generating some
visualization without actually any kind
of coherent technical definition that
says you know what precisely
parroted from the way people talk about
neural networks totally independently of
fairness sure I think the danger is that
you know if your goal is just classify
accurately and you speak in a kind of
sloppy way but the community at the end
of the day produces strong results on
holdout data that hold up you know
you're sort of could be forgiven whereas
you know if you're ultimately saying
this is this is my certificate this is
why you should be filled now comfortable
using machine learning and a critical
social setting where otherwise you
wouldn't just on account of this that
the end product is the interpretation
and not like some hand waving nonsense
that happens in the telling of the paper
along the way it's a very different kind
of setting anyway I'm over my time so
you know I'm happy to chat offline some
more but I think you know it's important
to be really careful I think we're at a
point where we are in danger of being
part of the problem and I think when we
you know when people are creating a
legislation now like in the GDP are
saying that like okay algorithms have to
be interval and we come and say I've got
the interprete Bilal Garifuna there's a
strong career incentive to do it to say
I've we proposed an algorithm and it is
interpretable and see the GDP are is
asking for this but you know there's
something fundamentally like ethically
wrong with it if what we're not actually
providing you know is something that
should give succor to anyone who is
subject to these sorts of decisions you
know we shouldn't claim his motivation
of a problem that we're not actually
addressing
[Applause]
so I
could you just say a couple words about
the breath of audience that would be
able to benefit from the mythos of model
interpretability
I mean you don't have to be a super
expert so say something about that IIIi
don't think there's uh I don't think I
ever entered math mode and writing that
paper so and I I wrote that paper and
maybe my second year of PhD and I had
been a musician up until I started PhD
so I don't think I knew any mathematics
at the time and as I think basically if
you have ever played an instrument or
not than you are able to drive as much
from it as anyone else
next speaker is Martha Minow from
Harvard Law School thank you and I get
my thanks also to the organizers of
everybody who's participating this has
been extraordinary the assignment of our
panel is governance and I think we've
had already really interesting
discussions about participation about
this match of the actual application
that was one minute you can't really
under major hello is that better yeah I
just think that so far in a panel on
governance we've already had some great
discussions about the role of
participation and perception and also
about kind of fundamental mismatch of
applications of certain kinds of
technologies or certain kinds of
problems I'm gonna sit back and just
talk a bit about what is governance and
what are the what's the map of
governance options and as I do so let me
just say I googled because why not data
governance and out came a lot of
cartoons none of which were funny truly
I mean they're what I suppose one that
was sort of funny was someone saying
well we usually mean something better
than because I said so I don't know but
based on the conversation so far I'm
thinking maybe we could do better on
what a data governance joke would be it
could be a group of people saying we're
working on it I'm not sure but so what
is governance governance in general it
means the elements society uses to
harness resources and organize
individuals and groups and good
governance in a liberal democracy is
usually defined as having seven
dimensions participatory responsive
effective efficient equitable inclusive
and following the rule of law now I
think a lot of the problems that we are
here assembled to talk about or that
most people who are not computer science
people don't think that having an
algorithm making decisions in your life
is participatory responsive equitable
inclusive or following the rule of law
whether it's efficient and whether it's
effective I think that those two terms
are closer and accuracy is of course a
dimension of fairness but just take as
an example the preamble to the South
African Constitution enacted after the
transition from apartheid and here I'm
thinking a bit about Rojas point about
maybe we could do something better than
neutrality the preamble to the
constitution for South Africa says that
this constitution of governance is
organized to try to undo unjust
injustice it's not a neutral activity
it's an effort to try to produce a
change in a society that has been unjust
and I guess I want to have that inform
my discussion but here's a map
yesterday's discussions seem to raise
just some examples of questions that
would be thrown into the governance
world who will say that the data in a
medical library
this is Evelyn's discussion should be
cabined or tagged for defective racial
terms and concepts another governance
question how do we strict the migration
of polygenetic risk scores or face
recognition or 23andme data or any other
technology from the intended use to
something else where it's not
appropriate or how do we build
equivalent or better oversight an
infrastructure that's like bioethics as
it has developed in the medical context
for the world of CS and machine learning
and AI can we do something better at the
moment we don't even have that and would
it be led by CS people would there be a
peer-review or certification process
would there be participation by
effective public says Alex was
describing and another example of a
governance question is who will define
good science and can we do that while
defending science in the time when
science itself may be in jeopardy those
are the kinds of questions so governance
always exists the question is what kinds
and therefore basic kinds that I think
surround us in this world in this time
markets with corporate boards being an
example of how markets are not natural
or neutral they are actually constructed
and designed by law with lots of
organizational institutional apurate
laws and regulation nor generally but
governance also includes norms and
ethics and peers peer pressure is maybe
one of the most effective forms of
governance but also peer networks and
then there are technical forms of
governance code data governance
algorithmic standards a smart contract
that's enforceable the minute the last
character is imposed
there are disappointments and lessons
from past efforts to have governance
this is generic although some already
are familiar in the world of algorithmic
governance there's short term profit
orientation and that's true of markets
but it's also true of personal ambition
I think as AK was describing about
career ambitions of people who want to
make their career around saying that
their algorithm is transparent there's
regulatory capture we create an
oversight body that ends up serving the
interests that it was supposed to be
guarding there's political retrenchment
on doing regulation like what happened
with 23andme and the Food and Drug
Administration there's a focus on
individualism like informed consent or
privacy and bias when in fact there's
systemic problems there is political and
intellectual weakness of alternatives to
a kind of Liberty libertarianism the
default position that's dominant in the
United States for the last 40 years is
there should not be regulation that the
market is the answer it's better to
break things and ask for forgiveness
than to ask for permission and no one is
more competent than us there is
technical world siloed from consequences
again backed by economic and sense
incentives that make improvements
difficult and there's a weakness of
norms and relying on norms which I think
many of us are coming to an awareness in
our current world where politicians
violate what everyone thought were norms
and nobody cares so who are the
stakeholders for governance this is kind
of obvious but I just thought it was
important to name them they're patients
and consumers and voters and students as
an example there's a for-profit sector
they're professionals and academics
there are formal governments at many
many levels there are informal
governance organizations nonprofit
organizations non-governmental entities
domestic and international and their
standard setting bodies and networks
their challenges for governance and
these are challenges that I think are
particularly
persistent and visible in the world of
algorithms justifying regulations
against the background of libertarianism
I've already described but also a kind
of technological progress a kind of
inevitability and a market is efficient
and we can just trust the progress there
are competing priorities for attention
there are a lot of things that people
care about right now beyond algorithmic
governance like you know kids at the
border and it's great to see a piece of
legislation introduced by Cory Booker in
the Senate it's not gonna get enacted
it's not going to have a hearing okay so
that's a big problem right now
they're competing goals and trade-offs
even if there was attention to something
like that bill speed versus accuracy
distributional concerns versus private
property protections and we don't
actually have good ways to resolve these
fundamental differences in goals there's
a timing and expertise gap here
particularly I think a lot about how
technology moves faster than any
regulatory system can and how the
ability of any government government to
hire the talent to keep up with what's
going on in the private sector or the
Academy it's not possible
there's coordination and preemption
problems as the u.s. basically has
failed to do much here well so Europe is
the leader but it's not just Europe you
know we have on issues for example of
regulation of hate on the Internet you
know we're gonna have we have now
competing regulations Singapore you UK
as well as the EU and then which system
runs there may be a race to the bottom
that means the lowest form the worst
form of regulation or race to the top
there's competition among jurisdictions
and then unanticipated consequences I
will cede my time for our collective
discussion but particularly to Pat but
just want to close by saying we can talk
about governance
I think that what's most exciting to me
about this gathering is the possibility
of a movement which is different than
governance a movement is about this idea
of change that where we are is not
adequate and even just borrowing
existing governance techniques from
other fields is not adequate because
we're dealing with the background of all
kinds of injustice particularly racial
and economic injustice in this country
but in the world as well and the
possibilities then of movement
activities that link together people who
are experts people who are students
people who want to put their different
fields of knowledge together
I love Rojas point about the arts I
teach a course called law and social
change and it has been very striking to
me looking at the history of different
movements how critical the arts have
been whether it's music or visuals for
the imagination parody big one narrative
coming up with a story where you can
imagine a different future science
fiction and also better cartoons thank
you
[Applause]